The first property states that if we add 2 logarithm's together that have the
same base then we can just multiply the numbers together. For example if we
have log base 2 of 4 plus log base 2 of 8 then we know that equals log base 2
of 4 times times, which equals 32. Now, this statement should make sense. We
know that log 2 of 4 equals 2. And we know that log base two of 8 equals three.
So if we add those together, we should get 5. And sure enough, the log base 2
of 32 equals 5. So whenever you add logarithms that have the same base, you can
really just multiply these arguments together. We just multiply x times y and
then take the log of it. So let's see if you can extend this reasoning. If we
have log base b of j, plus log base b of a, plus log base b of m, what would
that equal, if we did the log base b of this expression? In other words what
expression goes right here so that way the right-hand side of our equation is
equal to the left-hand side of our equation.